you're extremely popular on twitter you
have how many followers you have
3.5 yes right now okay and
and tell me you're very good at
following what you say are like the
social
media rules i mean i have rules that i
break a lot
um you know because like no like late
night tweeting and drunk tweeting
that's a hard time to enforce that
though
even on myself um and i try not to do
too many posts and
you know i i feel like you should have
to do a couple of silly posts or funny
posts for every like
self-promotional you can't just be like
out there promoting your own thing all
the time because you're ruining it for
everybody
right and um uh i feel like
it's really the place to say something
kind of funny and kind of honest because
i feel like on twitter i say things to
millions of people but i don't see them
so it's like i say stuff i wouldn't say
to somebody's face
but like on twitter and it's like this
release you know and instagram is the
place i go to be like i'm so fabulous
and wonderful and twitter's like i'm a
mess i'm really sorry
like can we all go have a drink and talk
about it so on instagram you're
you're amazing but on twitter you're
having a complete it's like
psychological collab yeah here's the
real deal it's a nightmare in here
yeah and what about i mean do you you
said that there's no
drunk i mean you try not to have some
wine or
have a few drinks and then treat that's
a huge problem for certain people andy
you're very
no no i don't mean that that you do it
but i think you're very disciplined
about that you
ah no i i've you're without some oh
thank you
thank you very much i have put out some
uh regrettable tweets
i i my problem more is the drunk
internet uh
shopping getting yeah just like getting
like
this hideous sweater oh right
now these sneakers that are made of
waffles yeah yeah that's more of the
problem
the tweets you know because i
get in trouble do you get in trouble for
stuff you say because you say some
pretty wild stuff
um no not really he doesn't know
i'm going to get one of these twitter
machines someday again
and i'll know what's going on i'm
imagining a curved top radio i got the
new twitter
now you think there should be a limit on
hashtags right yeah well i
i i find you know when people over
hashtag it's annoying except the rock do
you follow the rock
oh yeah yeah dwayne the rock johnson
i've never met him
and we talk on twitter sometimes and he
does like the most inspirational
like very serious like inspirational
tweets
and he's always like hash these long
hashtags about like
you know improving yourself and he's
always hashtagging about like team
bring it because we're all on team bring
it and i once asked him in a hashtag
is there a height limit for team bring
it right and he never got back to me
so my feelings are a little hurt right
but are you afraid that you
you're not tall enough to be on the
rocks team bring it yeah we'll be on
team bring it right she can be on team
bring it